Останні приготування напередодні першого вересня.
Ця школа в місті Буча хоче забути жахіття окупації і знову зустрічати дітей.
Тут були розташовані медикаменти під час окупації, які тільки можливі були,
тому що лікарня була вся з пораненими, і коли не вистачало лікарні для поранених,
то ми їм тут облаштували шпиталь.
Протягом усього літа школу ремонтували.
Директорка показує розбиті двері, які не встигли полагодити. Їх виламали російські військові.
Усе, що було в цьому кабінеті, винесено. Навіть елементарні особисті речі.
Оце не могли винести, то не винесли.
У підвалі облаштували укриття. Це обов’язкова умова, за якої можливе очне навчання.
Цій будівлі лише два роки, цокольний поверх - просторий, але з ним теж довелося попрацювати.
За словами директорки, прибирали, фарбували стіни й розставляли меблі вчителі разом з батьками.
Це все просто непридатне було для того, щоб знаходитися.
Не було повітря, не було вентиляції. Ось такого кольору було все. Підлоги не було.
Нині тут є три класні кімнати, кінозал, тренажерна зала, санвузли.
Лариса Сторожик розповідає, що сама перші кілька тижнів від початку війни була в Бучі.
Цей підвал став прихистком для її родини і ще чотирьох сотень людей.
Потім з уже окупованого міста жінка виїхала за кордон. Повернулася, щойно Бучу звільнили від росіян.
У мене було настільки багато натхнення і радості від того, що я тут,
що ми зможемо не впустити їх сюди знову, а якщо буде продовжуватися війна, то діти будуть у безпеці.
Наразі всі 100 відсотків учнів першого вересня ідуть на заняття. Тільки різна форма. Одні онлайн, екстернат.
Але всі учні, які навчалися до війни, приступлять до занять.
Особисто прийдуть в заклад дійсно менше - шістдесят відсотків.
Хтось іще не доїхав з-за кордону - ми чекаємо.
Після двох років карантину й пів року війни, першого вересня на шкільному подвір'ї знову гамірно.
Утім традиційної "лінійки" немає. Кожна паралель класів збирається у визначений час і рушає на перший урок.
Першокласниця Євангеліна з нетерпінням чекає, коли познайомиться з новими друзями.
Сьогодні буде хороший день.
Батьки Євангеліни вже оглянули укриття в школі, тому за свою доньку спокійні.
Були підготовчі збори, розповідали, як відбуватиметься навчальний процес.
Ми готові до цього. Життя триває, треба навчатися.
Петиція на сайті президента про заборону очного навчання набрала 25 тисяч підписів.
Серед аргументів стурбованих батьків те, що школи часто обстрілюють, п'ята частина шкіл і дитсадків - зруйновані.
Мама першокласника Марка сподівається, що в Бучі такого більше не станеться.
Це дійсно небезпека, і я щодня, віддаючи дитину в школу, буду розуміти, що по-різному можуть скластися обставини.
Але надіюсь, що все буде добре.
Не лякається повітряних тривог і шестикласник Владислав.
Він згадує, як поспіхом з батьками виїжджав з міста 24 лютого,
як бачив на відео ворожі гелікоптери над своїм подвір'ям.
Але тепер, каже, готовий до всього і радий, що повернувся до школи.
Тут поки не страшно. Страшно тоді, коли вони починають стріляти, або відправяли ракети. Це тоді страшно.
Або лякати своєю ядерною бомбою - це страшно.
Олена Андрієвич - викладає у цій школі хімію і біологію.
З цього року тут навчатимуться і обидва її сини.
Найбільше новому навчальному року радіє молодший - шестикласник Максим.
А що робити вдома? Телефон та й на диван. А так в школу ходиш, друзі є.
Ця родина вже знайома з укриттям у школі. Підвал став для них прихистком у перші два тижні війни.
Тепер вони кажуть, що звикли до нової реальності - з повітряними тривогами і постійною небезпекою.
До війни не можна звикнути. І страх того, що вона може знову сюди прийти…
Ну, але все добре, йдемо на навчання.
Хочеться відчувати, що життя налагоджується, життя йде далі, діти ростуть.
У новий рік що візьмемо? Щастя, добро, ще? Мирне небо візьмемо!
У третьокласників - перший урок. Це клас, об’єднаний з двох.
Після побажань на новий навчальний рік - інструктаж, що робити, коли завиє сирена.
Далі діти діляться думками - що для них Україна, говорять про війну, українських захисників і ворожих загарбників.
Який треба мати розум, щоб такої біди нам наробити?
- Курячий. - Курячий, супер.
У перший навчальний день у цій бучанській школі про війну лише говорили.
Жодного разу дітям і вчителям не довелося спускатися в укриття.